why would we get the short end of the
stick and now this will also connect
back to everything in woke world that
we're talking about lately well why why
was it so important to get her back well
she was sort of an apex predator of the
oppression Olympics uh pyramid right I
mean she's a black lesbian this is primo
stuffed people Paul wheelan's a white
dude I think straight what do we need
him for
Don lemon's very excited because this is
good for the gays I think I would be
remiss if we did not mention also the
importance this plays for the lgbtq
community since we've been talking about
black women this is big so this is for
the lgbtq community glad releasing a
statement obviously just I'm summarizing
here that they're happy and it shows the
the struggles and the danger that
members of the LGBT community face
around the world what the high hell are
you talking about lemon she's what she
wasn't arrested for being a lesbo she
was arrested for
spit take uh she wasn't arrested for
being a lesbian she was arrested for
smuggling drugs into the company into
the country this has nothing to do
with LGBT anything there's no such thing
as the LGBT community if there is I
don't want anything to do with it these
people are just all completely
ridiculous but that is the most
important thing you think Don lemon's
going to do a segment on Paul Whelan I
don't think so I don't think so